there's no one definition to make
something a country what decides of a
country as a country is essentially
whether or not other countries agree
that the country is indeed a country for
this reason counts the number of
countries in the world range from 189 to
196
each country decides which other
countries they recognize if 100 UN
member states suddenly recognize your
basement as its own country then it
generally would be accepted that your
basement is its own country there are
however a number of steps that any
prospective country founder needs to
take if they want have any shot at
getting international recognition the
first thing anyone needs to begin
creating country is a piece of land one
way to get it is to steal it of course
this involves having enough guns to
defend your territory this would also be
problematic for when your country gets
the stage which legitimacy is reviewed
by other nations but this method has
worked before the easier method is the
claim unclaimed land however with the
advent of satellite imaging and modern
cartography there really are no islands
or large pieces of territory that are
not known despite this there is a small
number of places not governed or claimed
by any recognized government one of the
better-known recent claims happen in an
area unclaimed by both Croatia and
Serbia
along the Danube River the border
between the two countries this micro
nation known as liberland has not
received any international recognition
and has been denounced by a number of
nations but it still affirms its
legitimacy based off the lack of
previous claim to its land it's Lane is
actually 17 times larger than the land
of the smallest recognized country the
Vatican Serbia did agree that liberland
did not infringe upon its territory but
also dismiss the endeavor as frivolous
other new nations have had more success
and international recognition
most of these are partially recognized
nations that split away from a more
recognized state with the backing of the
people within the territory an example
of this is South Ossetia which blow away
from Georgia in 1990 and is currently
recognized by Russia Nicaragua Venezuela
and Nauru probably the best known and
most hotly contested recently formed
nation is the state of Palestine 136
Nations recognized the Palestine and in
2012 it was designated
the United Nations as a non-member
observer State one other option for
unclaimed land is Antarctica a large
section of land known as the Mary Byrd
land has not been claimed by any
recognized nation one issue with this
option is the United Nations is
Antartica treaty which states that no
new claim or enlargement of an existing
claim to territorial sovereignty shall
be asserted while the present treaty is
in force
there are claims that pre-exists this
treaty by severing different nations
although the legitimacy of these claims
is disputed given the treaty in addition
to the Antarctic Treaty issue
establishing a sovereign nation in
Antarctica would be difficult because
the next step in the process a nation is
created to serve its people and without
people there is no nation there are
always people in Antarctica but these
people do not constitute a permanent
population because they are primarily
there for research or tourism and none
stay in Antarctica for more than a few
years interestingly eleven babies have
been born in Antarctica but they
generally have taken the citizenship of
their parents countries a permanent
population is one of the most basic
qualifiers for statehood a sustainable
independent nation would be near
impossible in Antarctica any settlement
would have no real economy and no way to
naturally produce food however there are
talks of Antarctica having oil and if
this is the case a sovereign and
potentially prosperous nation could be
established in a hostile environment
much like the United Arab Emirates
similar to the dozens of Antarctic
micronation claims liberland struggles
with a lack of permanent population the
founders attempts to re-enter the
territory have been blocked by both
Serbia and Croatia at this point it
seems unlikely that a permanent
population will be established in the
near future and for this reason the
future of liberland is bleak a
well-formed government is probably the
most important aspect dictating the
success of your new country there are
tons of forms of government but concern
you're forming this country in the 25th
century you're likely to base the
government on John Locke's principles of
government Locke's principles
essentially say that in nature everybody
has the right to life health liberty or
possessions you might notice the sim
Lari between this and another famous
document according to Locke in a natural
society that is without a government
these rights are not protected because
there is no higher power to do so so in
exchange for taking away part of these
rights for example liberty when in
prison or property when taxed the
government acts to protect the very same
rights Locke also states that government
only works when there is a common belief
in the abstract idea or illusion of
government and therefore a government
can only really exist when the people
are behind it this is the reason that
autocratic or absolutist government
rarely work in modern society so now
keeping these principles in mind in a
constitution every single recognized
country in the world either has a
constitution or some substitution to it
this is not a complicated process I
won't go into too much detail but
essentially any country must have a set
of laws principles and entities that
make up the country and the Constitution
works define and specify these this is
where all your work comes under scrutiny
gaining international recognition is by
far the most difficult step in the
country creating process - especially
hundreds of years for new countries to
be fully or near fully recognized
chances are that unless you have an
overwhelming backing from the people
within your country a good reason for
the establishment of your new nation
absolutely undisputed territory and a
well-balanced democratic government you
won't be recognized by any UN member
states the chances of a new well
recognized nation outside of Africa or
the Balkans is unlikely the governments
are too well established or stable
outside of these areas the final step to
gain undisputed recognition is to be
admitted to the United Nations any
application is reviewed by the Security
Council composed of China France the
Russian Federation the United Kingdom of
Great Britain in Northern Ireland the
United States of America and a rotating
group of ten others if 10 of the 15 vote
in favor of your country congratulations
you just join the United Nations by most
metrics you're now a country of course
other united nation members still can
fail to recognise you and there are
plenty of UN member states that are not
fully recognized however that's
topic for another time so good luck with
your new country thanks for watching and
see you next time
the 8.9 mile gap between the European
and African continent known as the
Strait of Gibraltar is home to multiple
strange territories and borders on the
European side which is 2.6 square miles
British overseas territory named
Gibraltar this means that Britain sure
is a small land border with Spain